it has been a minute it's been a minute
it has been a minute hey
i am here today to talk to you about
songwriting
and a little bit about song productions
you know that i love to show you the
behind the scenes of any creative
project that i am doing and for a while
now you have been asking how i write
songs and how jamie and i produce them
so that is what this video is all about
i'll be digging in deep to the last song
that i released which is called we feel
it too and i think this one's quite
interesting because
it was uh recorded entirely from home
because it was made during the big
corona yeah
and nobody could leave their houses for
quite a while and some still can't so i
think it will be hopefully informative
because this shows that anyone can
create a song um from the comfort or
confines
if you will of your bedroom
during this video i will take you
through my process of how i create a
song from nothing and then how to turn
that song into something magical with
production
um and i also want to show you how i
made the music video for that song but
that's gonna have to be in another video
because i started to write this script
and it got way too long so we're just
gonna focus on music today all of the
different sections of this video will be
put into the timeline so feel free to
check it out and skip to whichever parts
interest you most so let's talk about
creating a song entirely from scratch
and my number one tip is to know your
limitations
we all have parts of our creative
process that we don't feel
as confident in and mine is my
musical ability with instruments i know
i am not the the best guitarist in the
world so when i am writing a new song i
do try and push myself but i also keep
my own limits in mind so that i can play
a song confidently
[Music]
and this is fine we can't be good at
everything and knowing your limitations
i think really does help with creativity
because you can play around within your
realms of possibility and your own skill
set instead of trying to reach for
something beyond that and then just
getting frustrated that you can't reach
it a good way to know your limitations
is to
learn other people's songs to play
covers of those songs this will teach
you new chords new strumming patterns
and you can kind of get a feel for what
comes naturally and what you need to
work more on i personally
find it difficult to stay motivated when
i'm following like a guitar tutorial or
a lesson
because i need an end goal to work
towards so if i'm learning a song that i
really want to play and then let's say i
can't get a chord right or a strumming
pattern this gives me so much more
motivation to nail that chord because i
know i really want to play the song and
this goes nicely into melody
so playing other people's songs gives
you a nice idea of what chords work well
together what strumming patterns are
nice and then you can kind of take
inspiration from this and put it into
your own songs make them unique of
course but there's nothing wrong with
taking a pinch of inspiration from here
and there and eventually once you get
into the swing of playing and learning
new songs you'll start to instinctually
understand what chords work well
together is instinctually a word
not sure
a lot of the time i will play a chord
and i'll instinctively know which chord
i want to play after that even if i'm
not quite sure exactly what chord it is
i just know what it sounds like it's all
about experimenting learning and
trusting your instincts when writing a
song i often have the intent to play it
live someday and because of this i
usually go for more
slow
strumming patterns or plucking patterns
just so that i know that i will be able
to play it confidently if i wear up on a
stage so once i find a nice progression
of chords and a strumming or plucking
sequence i will then just kind of come
along to it really most of the time at
this point i'm not actually focusing on
what i want to say i'm more
humming and just finding a
pitch and a rhythm
that is fun to sing and also catchy and
goes along with the melody really nicely
so let's now talk about the lyrics
i do sing all the time so with a lot of
this stuff it really is just kind of
what you enjoy and i think if you enjoy
singing and playing music and you're
coming up with lyrics whatever you think
your thing is you'll probably do it in
your day-to-day without even realizing
and i sing songs about everything and
they're not
most of the time not very good but it's
fun to do so let me tell you my three
main ways that i come up with the lyrics
from my songs okay so number one and
this is probably the one that you're
expecting i already have a
idea of the topic that i'd like to sing
about when i sit down to write a song
but i'm not sure exactly what those
lyrics are yet
um this is usually when i'm feeling kind
of low or conflicted and i'm writing a
song to understand these feelings more
within myself writing songs can be very
therapeutic number two is actually when
i'm working out the melody and when i'm
humming and trying to find that nice
pitch and rhythm i might just come off
with a random line that i really like
the sound of and i might find a nice
rhine that goes along with that
and it's more about just kind of going
with the flow that way and three and
this is a really good way especially
when you're kind of feeling in a bit of
a creative rut and you you feel like you
can't do this anymore which honestly i
have been feeling recently
is i look back at old poems that i've
written over the many many years ever
since i could honestly remember i've
been writing down poems
rhymes even just ideas they don't
necessarily have to be a full-fledged
poem or rhyme yet
whenever i've gotten them like if i'm
eating breakfast in the shower at
bedtime that always happens when you're
trying to go to sleep and something pops
in your head and you go wow that's a
really cool idea i need to write it down
it might never lead to anything
but it's never going to lead to anything
if you never write it down because
you'll never remember it again so
i keep all of my
my poems my ideas my thoughts whatever
in google keep but you can do it in your
phone you can do it in a physical
journal whatever works for you i just
say write things down whenever you get
some good ideas and you never know when
you might want to look through them and
you get inspired by yourself your past
self
so this song in particular was written
kind of in style number one it was when
the pandemic had just started
my first experience working from home
not seeing loved ones being locked up in
my bedroom
great times and i needed to have a
release i needed to write it down
somewhere
and just figure out what i was feeling
really
um so i came up with the the plucking
pattern first and the chords because
also i was trying to learn plucking on
the guitar when i wrote this song
and then came out the first line
i know
you find it hard
when you're
up
[Music]
anyway
coming off the back of lyrics would be
your song structure
so a well-established song structure as
we probably already know is verse chorus
versus chorus bridge and maybe an alas
chorus i try not to over complicate the
structures of my songs too much because
i mean it works for a reason but i do
try and kind of just kind of play around
with viruses chorus intro outro maybe
you can make things slightly different
there
um
i think that's how
you can have a bit more fun with it
instead of trying to reinvent the wheel
maybe just
start your song with a chorus instead of
a verse oh
that's kind of how you could mix it up
if you wanted to i would say however
that it is always fun for both you and
the listener to add uh maybe a bridge or
just something to mix up the end of your
song um around the third verse that's
what i try and do especially when i
i'm not so gifted on the guitar so
usually it does sound very very samey so
i'll try and maybe sing a different way
or just add a few extra chords
or make the strumming pattern slightly
different
in the third brass just to give it
something that's a little bit of a oof
and it's always nice to know that the
end is coming and there's there's a
little bit of change there but overall
if you get a good feel for the fast
verse and then the first chorus i really
feel like it kind of just flows from
there and you've just got to trust your
instincts just keep going over what you
have keep practicing it and even if you
have to step away from your instruments
keep singing the song and keep humming
it to yourself you never know when a
spark of inspiration is going to hit
i remember i was writing a song
called desire of more for a long time
and i had no idea what to do with third
verse for maybe a year and then all of a
sudden it just hit me in the shower
obviously in the shower but these things
happen everything you wanted
does it match up to
what you saw
so acoustic recording once i am happy
with the song i will record it
acoustically i think there's something
really beautiful about a raw piece of
music that's recorded as if
you were there listening to it live in
person and i know that if i record it
like this then i can always revisit it
in the future to polish it up to record
these acoustic recordings i usually just
use a yeti nano and my macbook which is
definitely on its way out but i do this
because i can record it anyway i can
record it on my bed i can even take it
to the woods if i want to
um my macbook is extremely portable and
the yeti nano is a teeny tiny mic so it
still sounds great but i'm not confined
to sitting by my pc i record using
garageband
but i like garageband for a little
acoustic recording and it's so easy just
to shove a little bit of reverb on there
to make it sound a bit better and that's
it that's done i did actually upload an
acoustic version of we feel it too about
a year and a half before i uploaded the
polished version so that's a a really
good example of kind of how i do it okay
so
now we're going to talk about song
production i mean
all i can say here is find a brilliant
producer
the end
no don't worry there's definitely more
things i can say but finding a brilliant
producer is extremely extremely helpful
of course you can always learn music
production yourself if you can find the
time for that which would be great but
you don't have to do everything you
don't have to be good at everything like
i said at the beginning of this video so
if you have the opportunity to
collaborate with someone else
that you feel
understands your vision could work well
with you and you like what they do
go for it what have you got to lose
sometimes the best ideas actually come
from a collaboration i've had the
pleasure of working with jamie at
horizon productions for many years now
and he has really helped me to elevate
my music to a whole new standard so big
thank you big thank you to jamie
very much so usually i visit his studio
and we will record there with all of his
fancy equipment
but of course
i was not allowed outside like all of us
so i recorded this entirely from home
and sent him the war versions for him to
produce
at his studio so this was quite a
learning curve let's talk a bit about
some narrative when bringing a song to
production i am not the producer i do
not know all of the cool fancy producer
stuff
what i do know is narrative
and i know why i wrote my song and what
i want my song to convey i am
narratively led in a lot of the things
that i create um and i really do see my
songs as stories especially when they're
going through the production process
before we start any work i'll write a
big document which includes the song
narrative the theme direction
the lyrics and any reference songs so
that the producer and i are on the same
level and we can kind of
share the same vision for the song
moving forward sometimes we even do make
a collaborative spotify playlist so we
can kind of put songs in there that we
think are relevant to what we're working
on but usually that's more for
for larger projects like eps
future ep
this song's theme was isolation so i
really wanted to keep it quite stripped
back
to give the audience the feeling that
they were listening to something very
intimate i imagined it as though the
listener would be right there with me in
my bedroom ambience
so the producer jamie and i thought that
adding some ambience would be a really
nice way of adding like a human layer to
the song which fits very nicely with the
narrative when in lockdown the simple
joy of kind of being around people and
nature
while everything was living their
day-to-day lives was something that i
actually very much missed even as an
introvert i really craved life beyond my
own four walls after a while
um so when it was more safe i went out
and bought a
zoom h1n portable microphone and i took
it to my local park i also bought a
windshield which is very important if
you are recording in england it's very
windy here
but i ended up recording distant sounds
of children playing people talking
dogs
birds rustling in amongst the tree
leaves it was very nice any talking was
mostly ineligible as i didn't want to
invade anybody's privacy um however
there is this really cute exchange
between a mum and her son about plums
and i thought it was so cute so i ended
the song with that but fingers crossed
they don't mind
[Music]
so i wanted this ambience to be a part
of the song to remind us
that the world is still out there and
waiting for us
no matter how hard it gets the ambience
was used throughout the whole song with
it being more prominent at the beginning
and the end of the song to kind of tie
it together in a nice little bow however
we did also make it very prominent in
the third verse as i say the lines
[Music]
it kind of comes in louder as if you
have just opened a window
whoa
i think it's really small details like
that that
kind of help build towards the the
narrative and the theme that that i was
talking about earlier okay so after the
ambience was recording my guitar so i
recorded my guitar on my pc with my blue
yeti microphone
and uh the software of reaper i did
attempt to play with a metronome that
was at uh 92 beats per minute bpm
but i still find playing to a metronome
pretty difficult so it took me a good
few tries to get it right the best way
that i found to do this was to focus on
trying to get at least three decent
takes of each part of the song so i kind
of
broke up the song
so i did the verses individually the
choruses individually
this alleviated the pressure on myself
because i wasn't trying to play the
whole song through
perfectly my concentration uh kept
breaking my timing kept going strange if
i had tried to play the whole entire
song through so at the end of the day it
worked better for me for jamie for the
song as a whole for me to play it bit by
bit by recording multiple takes of each
section jaime could then
use them and hopefully there would be at
least one good one in the bunch which
there were so that's good we did have
some audio issues where because i am not
in his lovely soundproof studio
you could hear some background noise
unfortunately i did try to
soundproof my room as best that i could
i do have some soundproof panels on my
wall
i tried to get a sheet next to the
microphone
but ultimately it's not going to be as
good as the studio
with my green screen most notably the
background noise was actually from the
metronome coming from my headphones so i
had to turn that right down which made
playing to a
metronome even harder
um but we did it in the end and jamie
did
amazing amazing job of removing that
background noise so thank you jimmy
here's a little insight into jamie's
workflow when cleaning up the guitar the
first thing i'm using on everything is
noise reduction because it's recording
in her room
there was computer noise ambient noise
hiss from the preamps over many tracks
playing together this noise will add up
so just doing a bit of reduction on each
track can just lower that noise a little
bit i just play a before and after on
the guitar
it's probably quite a subtle thing on
the guitar next
i'm doing a little bit of dynamic eq
there was a bit of a node here that was
jumping up and down
and as you see it's around here it's
just kind of tucking it away as it comes
in then an eq
there's an eq i use a lot shep 73 it's a
1073 emulation and this i'm just using
to make the track sound a little bit
better okay so vocals
this is the fun part
so once the ambience and the guitar was
all put together it was time for me to
record my vocals i did this again on my
pc using my blue yeti microphone and the
software of reaper
on my microphones on an arm so i could
make it stand up so i could stand up and
sing into it which is great very much
like the guitar parts i did
sing each part individually versus
individually courses individually and
the end as well because i always feel
like the end is something you really
want to get right and then i sense jamie
multiple takes so we could kind of mix
and match to see what we liked best i
can be really picky when it comes to my
own voice so there were a good few weeks
where i was re-singing parts
however
at the end of the day i just had to know
when to stop you can keep working on
something forever and it's never going
to be perfect
so for me what really helps with this is
to give myself soft deadlines and if i
know that i'm coming upon one i then
need to reflect and ask myself
you know
is this project actually
bad do i need to spend more time on it
or am i just being picky once the main
vocals were in we could then add the
harmonies and this is always a really
collaborative process between me and
jamie we'll both come up with ideas for
harmonies and see which ones work best
listen
when we've chosen which harmonies we
want to do i will then uh record
multiple takes of these harmonies and
instead of jamie using only one of these
takes he'll actually use them all and
he'll layer them together so you get
this really nice kind of airy dreamlike
quality to the harmonies which we both
really really like you know what i might
as well just let jamie show you first
[Music]
eq and saturation
[Music]
listen to the sounds
then that's going through this
compressor again this is only doing a
little bit of compression nothing major
and then the reverb
called phoenix verb
[Music]
and then mixing the song in cubase so
jamie the producer at horizon
productions mixed this whole song in
cubase and also used bus processing
to fine-tune the final mix i am no
expert in this field however he did make
an extensive video detailing the behind
the scenes process of the production for
this song so i will put that video in
the description down below check it out
if you want to know more about music
production
and after that it was just making the
music video it was just making the music
video
that will be a whole new video that i
will record separately because a lot
went into that
but i really really do want to show you
because i think that creating a music
video especially in a game engine like
how i do it it opens up so many
possibilities and it allows you to
create the whole thing from home which
especially nowadays is really really
useful if you want to know more about
that then stay tuned
click the bell subscribe do all of that
stuff give this video a like yeah
also i just want to say please before we
go
have fun at the end of the day music is
an artistic expression and there's no
point to any of it
if you don't feel like you're getting
something out of it personally
it's not what i do full-time
but i really do find it a fulfilling
part of my life and i i honestly can't
imagine my life without it because i use
it
to express my emotions and even
understand myself a little bit better
anyway i hope this insight into my
songwriting song creating process
has been a little bit informative or at
least entertaining for you to watch
i'm happy to be back and i'm really
looking forward to showing you the
behind the scenes of the music video as
well because that was a really fun one
to make and i'm very proud of it i think
it looks awesome and i think jamie did
an amazing job as usual and i am really
freaking excited to
i said freaking it doesn't matter okay
i'm really freaking excited to
go back to the studio and
keep working on my music and make this
second dp
it's gonna be so good thanks to everyone
who does listen to the music that jamie
and i make
the
raw little acoustic songs that i put up
on youtube
i i really do appreciate it i honestly
never thought when i was younger writing
songs that i would ever have
any type of audience so
it really is a dream come true i'm yeah
i'm humbled thank you
if you want to see more of me make sure
that you catch me
on thursdays over on twitch where i'll
be streaming weekly i am not going to be
streaming on youtube weekly anymore
but
do go over to twitch give me a follow
there or subscribe if you're feeling
generous i have done a complete revamp
of
my twitch my youtube my patreon i'm
trying to take everything a little bit
more seriously this year so
wish me luck
we'll see how we go
um but yeah i'm looking forward to
getting getting back into it this year
with you i feel like i've taken a really
long break okay i'm gonna stop blabbing
now
have a lovely day evening i'll see you
in the next video and
bye
i know
you find it hard when you're
important
[Music]
and i know
you feel alone
inside your home is no longer
a
place of
rest and i know
you try your best
[Music]
just know
[Music]
we feel
it too
just
like
with you